c'est un peureux il a peur d'être tué il
a peur d'être battu il a peur d'être
agressé et donc il tue avant d'être tué
c'est un Lucky Luke
et les routier bonsoir vous êtes
rédacteur en chef au Nouvel Observateur
ou vous suivez les questions économiques
et vous êtes aussi l'auteur de
best-sellers consacré à Bernard Tapie à
l'affaire Elf le fameux forage en eau
profonde que vous avez écrit avec
Valérie leble et vous publiez chez Albin
Michel un livre qui s'appelle l'ange
exterminateur la vraie vie de Bernard
Arnault alors dans l'ange exterminateur
vous racontez comment Bernard Arnault le
patron de LVMH qui est parti il y a 20
ans d'une PME de province et devenu
l'homme le plus riche de France voilà
enfin d'après ce que vous écrivez voilà
maintenant tellement de problèmes avec
les avocats avec ce bouquin que je vais
dire d'après ce que vous écrivez toutes
mes phrases vont commencer par d'après
vous ou est-il exact où vous affirmez et
Laurent je compte sur toi pour faire
attention
[Applaudissements]
la à mi-temps
ce que je vais dire à mes amis
téléspectateurs c'est que toute façon ce
qui est dans le bouquin on peut pas
vraiment le raconter à la télé alors
faites-moi confiance acheter le voilà
comme ça au moins c'est clair
c'était Éric routier merci
alors plus sérieusement vous écrivez
vous auriez écrit oui
que Bernard Arnault a tout fait pour
empêcher la la sortie du livre et
plusieurs patrons vous ont fait
clairement savoir que en publiant ce
bouquin vous mettiez votre avenir
professionnel en danger si je ne
publiais pas je m'étais mon avenir
personnel dans une voie royale les
stablissement vous serez reconnaissants
de ne pas publier il y a déjà plusieurs
livres consacrés pendant Arnaud qui ne
sont jamais sortis donc il y en a eu un
chez Audi Jacob et un chez Robert
Laffont
obligé aussi de changer d'éditeur
grassés qui étaient l'éditeur de votre
livre précédent a préféré passer le bébé
Albin Michel oui ça s'est passé de façon
assez harmonieuse mais j'ai tout d'un
coup j'ai compris que si j'allais au
bout je crois qu'ils auraient été au
bout mais ça les arrangeait que
d'ailleurs Olivier général patron de
gracem a dit qui est un m'a dit écoute
au rugby quand on veut marquer un essai
qui a un gros master en face et bah vaut
mieux passer la balle que de se payer le
master en gros c'est et donc ça c'est
fait gentiment donc Saint Michel qui
sort le bouquin pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont plus courageux ils ont moins peur
des masters chez Albin Michel j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est dans une phase
assez offensive
alors on vous a aussi accusé les
routiers de rouler pour François Pinault
qui est le grand ennemi de Bernard
Arnault
mais cette idiot parce que j'ai pas
besoin de parrain comme Pino pour faire
mon job de les trois quarts du bouquin
sont quand même avant puis nous arrivent
donc je vois pas comment il aurait pu
d'aider trois trois facettes non mais
c'est la mentalité des grands patrons
jamais ils imaginent qu'on puisse faire
une démarche normale d'un journaliste
normal d'un enquêteur normal à
l'américaine vous racontez que pendant
votre travail vous avez eu affaire à des
gens absolument terrifiés qui vous
donner des rendez-vous dans des endroits
absolument ultra secrets il y a une part
de la pression de Bernard Arnault mais
sur les gens avec qui il travaille ou
ceux avec qui il a travaillé
de vue depuis 20 ans j'ai passé des
coups de fil et me rappeler en disant on
peut pas on veut pas mais c'était c'est
assez étonnant il y a une vraiment un
climat autour de lui de à la fois de
respect d'ailleurs de respect pour le
personnage qui est quand même
extrêmement puissant et de crainte c'est
clair alors dans le livre vous dites NON
vous affirmez c'est ça que je veux dire
dans le livre
[Rires]
utilise les services d'une agence de
détective qui s'appelle l'agence crawl
alors c'est quoi l'agence Crolles c'est
une agence qui a été créée à la fin des
années 70 quand Jimmy Carter a voulu
faire le ménage dans la CIA donc il a
viré la moitié de la des agents de la
cigale qui sont regroupés qu'on fait une
agence qui reste extrêmement liée à la
CIA qui est dans le monde entier et qui
a une activité d'espionnage économique
extrêmement puissante donc j'ai
effectivement c'est pas de supputations
j'ai consulté des documents et tout si
vous avez eu accès à des documents
internes de l'agence crawl et le patron
d'ailleurs François Valdman a été viré
merci bravo
à cause du bouquin
mais non mais c'est c'est des pratiques
qui sont plus fréquentes contre le croit
mais enfin Albert c'est un peu le sang
quand on voit les documents sa glace un
peu le son le problème d'Arnaud c'est
que comme il a il a une image
extrêmement lisse qui veut il veut il
veut donner une image de lui parfaite
bon il y a un vrai double langage donc
c'est très très surprenant quoi quand au
même moment il dit un bien fou de de Tom
Ford Dominique sont les patrons de Gucci
qui veut à l'époque il veut les bouffer
et en même temps LVMH passe un contrat
crawl pour les pour les disqualifier en
fait il trouve rien d'ailleurs à un
moment quand il voulait racheter
Vuitton le patron à l'époque était
Monsieur Henri Racamier un vieux
monsieur comme ça très vieille France et
tous les journaux de de France et de
Navarre ont reçu une lettre de Le Pen
remerciant monsieur racamié pour les
dons qu'il avait fait pour sa campagne
c'est un fou c'est un faux le canard
n'avait publié à l'époque et c'est six
mois après c'était excusé c'était un
faux Le Pen 15 jours après Le Pen devait
être assez content de voir ça aussi donc
il a mis trois semaines à des lentilles
mais ça a été des lentilles c'était un
faux et et les photos de la boutique
Vuitton en 1942 avec vieilles qui sont
arrivés dans pas mal de rédaction avec
marqué interdit aux Juifs c'était un
faux non c'est vrai mais c'était
je je pensais de rire je pense que
beaucoup de boutiques qui avaient marqué
ça mais c'était un avalgame terrible
quoi vous avez pas peur et les routiers
que Monsieur Bernard Arnault coupe la
publicité qu'il fait dans Le Nouvel
Observateur journal qui vous emploie non
j'ai pas peur j'ai pas peur parce que il
est tout sauf stupide que ça se
retournerait contre lui qu'en plus
routier c'est routier love cellops que
je pense pas qu'il ferait ça s'il le
fait il fera une bêtise en plus je vais
faire la pub de mon journal c'est quand
même un excellent support de pub pour
les marques si déjà qu'il en donne pas
au point parce que c'est Pinot si on
donne pas à l'OPS pour L'Express un peu
quoi
alors pourquoi l'ange exterminateur
quand on le voit il est parfait il est
gentil il est merveilleux il est calme
il est placé il est bon il y a un peu
ombrageux il est un peu susceptible
d'être fou comme ça bon mais quand on
regarde la réalité des faits c'est un
tueur
c'est un peureux il a peur d'être tué il
a peur d'être battu il a peur d'être
agressé et donc il tue avant d'être tué
Lucky Luke maintenant la question que
tout le monde se pose
[Musique]
comment fait-on pour devenir aussi riche
ah ça c'est c'est compliqué fascinant
tout le monde le ferait donc on pourra
d'abord on part avec 40 millions ça aide
c'est une entreprise familiale par 40
millions bon c'est une entreprise de
construction ce qui aime pas d'argent on
la vend on prend 40 millions on fait une
entreprise de promotion faire une aile à
la mer faire une férinel à la montagne
et ensuite
on prend contrôle de Boussac c'est à
dire on arrive avec son son blazer bleu
ces boutons doré sans dire provincial
avec un projet précis alors qu'il y a
tout un mâle Strom de gens qui veulent
bouffer Boussac et tout ils ne veulent
que dire on arrive avec une tête
d'enfant et Fabius vous donne Boussac ça
aide ensuite donc on tient à côté bien
donc ensuite on tire passer promesse on
vend tout ce qui est la laine le textile
et ça on garde Dior Conforama
et puis ensuite 5 6 ans après et L VMH
il y a deux il y a deux patrons qui se
battent entre eux
on va entre les deux on fait on va vers
là on va vers l'autre on joue l'un
contre l'autre et tout d'un coup on
emprunte 25 milliards au créditaires de
jour ah oui il fait partie de ces grands
patrons français qui ont réussi grâce
auprès des banques en fait oui mais on
n'est pas il a remboursé parce que ça
mais il faut quand même oser emprunter
25 milliards de jours il avait pas le
premier sous enfin il avait bon et il
prend LVMH et ensuite alors il y a
ensuite c'est des mécanismes extrêmement
compliqués donc on peut pas
mais il y a des cascades de trucs comme
ça on fait de l'argent c'est comme la
France du haut la France du bas il y a
des cascades des accidents minoritaires
et d'une autre l'argent du bas va en
haut plus vite qu'il ne devrait
semble-t-il donc apparemment c'est pas
la portée de tout le monde
et puis les 40 millions de départ c'est
quand même c'est pas inutile quoi vous
expliquer ça très bien alors il y a deux
raisons donc d'acheter le bouquin des
rires routier l'ange exterminateur la
vraie vie de Bernard Arnault chez Albert
Michel la première c'est d'abord tout
savoir sur l'homme le plus riche de
France parce que c'est pas effectivement
très connu ce que vous racontez et puis
la deuxième c'est d'essayer de faire
comme lui voilà et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu